let's camp let's hear for you guys hello
gangsters good to be here with my homies
I love doing stand-up comedy it's one of
my favorite things but it can get very
intense at times sometimes I wish I was
a painter because I've never been
painting a picture and had the canvas be
like boo that doesn't look like a tree
you should quit draw something Asian a
lot of people say fucked-up things to me
whether my friends was like dude Hans
you got such an Asian smile I was like
oh thanks now I get to think about how
I'm physically different from everyone
around me every time I feel happiness my
name is Hans that's my real name it's a
weird name but I think it's even weirder
that I had a white friend named Tanner
Jenner than what it should be like hey
this is my Mexican friend Tanner this is
my black friend Dennis let's not race
accession suffixes I love being Asian I
don't mind my so much racist to me
because I know that they're crazy
you hate respectful people who keep to
themselves okay good luck finding an
affordable car we're trying to help I am
single I have yet to find my soul mate
I'm beginning to think maybe it's her
fault she should get out more
she seems like a loser I think I could
do better our friends like dude we're so
lucky we're not gay if we're gay that
means most of the gender that were
attracted to would it be attracted to
his back I was like well can't even
imagine they must cry a lot
my friends like Hans you should learn
how to talk to girls you're really bad
at that maybe or maybe girls should
learn how to listen to Hans why don't
you want to hear about the Federal
Reserve Board a party was enough this
one girl was like my vagina is a 3d
printer I was like that's not even
accurate your womb is a 3d printer your
vagina is a tray
and atomically it's not even a very good
3d printer it only prints one thing with
lots of errors takes nine months to
print and the whole time is printing
it's complaining I don't want to look
for in a printer I'm glad that a women
give birth on that man don't I feel like
if my bro friends gave birth they feel
up man I've been eating so much protein
and creatine during the second trimester
this baby's like 20 pounds already bro
check out his abs and ultrasound I don't
understand carpool lanes I feel like
carpool lanes like society saying hey
you know how you lonely why don't you do
that for longer now take the long way
home think about it watch people with
friends whizzing by you that's supposed
to help my sister just got back from a
mission trip if you don't know that as a
mission trip is when Americans go to
third-world countries to get new profile
pictures a photo shoot we grew up
Christian as an Asian household which is
kind of weird because the people who
wrote the Bible didn't even seem to know
that Asians existed can't even drop us a
line hey Jase good job on the wall back
to the Jews I love my sister she's a
vegan if you don't know what a vegan is
those are people who ruin your dinner
plans and then are really proud about it
she acts like she's better than me but
she's guilty of a crime way worse than
the murder of animals and that's a crime
of annoying a human what's the point of
having the healthiest body in the world
if your personality makes people want to
strangle you in your sleep
would you keep on now if I could get her
to shut up during dinner I would eat two
koala bears in front of her all right
that's my time hey guys so much
one more time Hans can you guys right I
knew it